let's try efore because last time d40
works so well
alrighty 9 f3 and and what else
all right let's get in see for this is
an accelerated drag and I do have I
believe it's an accelerated dragon right
without d6 does allow for c4 this was a
great fear of mine very early on in my
chess playing career I I don't think I
ever shared this before but um I
remember always thinking if somebody
went with that fiend keto well first off
the the word fiend kettle was was like a
little bit intimidating to me and
because I didn't really know it was like
a new word to me and I just I assumed
that if my opponent was going with those
type of maneuvers that they really
really knew what they were doing and and
you know I always played not so
confidently early on even still today
but um yeah there's a quick little tip I
feared the fiend keto alrighty so I have
d4 watched over here and what else what
is the scoop
[Music]
all right a six is looking at that b5
advance at some point not right away
c6 hangs I have a space advantage okay
some pieces are coming off the board
here might be seeing Knight d7 or that
which is a bit unusual
I want the LightScribe bishops off the
board
and I want my knight to be able to sit
on d5 hmm I think Queen d3 is a good
move I have two things in mind with this
just connect my rooks it's allowing for
route to d1 but I might also want to
play here and after a capture I am you
know watching out for maybe an f5 break
by having my queen on this diagonal now
Knight d5 hmm
95 95 95 what do I do after that Bishop
takes pawn takes the rooks our intention
the Queen come out to a hmm yeah she's
very active there isn't she
what a pest what about b3 yeah well
that's not to be too quick to pull the
trigger on the 95 move just go with the
3 and then and then get my other rook on
the D file and put pressure on d6 all
right yeah
then then what is our black and a half
to do here what is he gonna have to do
a little bit of a time edge okay and now
now I'm gonna win upon because this move
isn't working out deflection and you
know what I was a little bit in the last
game analysis I did Game seven of the
World Chess Championship there was a
particular Bishop move that when I
initially viewed the game I was I was
wanting to point it out during the video
but I didn't it was a possibility for
black to play a Bishop to f4 move for
those of you that are familiar with that
game a Bishop f4 move before playing
Queen to b8 I wish I would have
remembered to touch on that particular
move
is there any rush we're taking that rook
not seeing it I think actually black is
in a very very serious bind I really
can't go anywhere if my bishop remains
on b6 there's no pawn break on the Queen
side
okay so now it's instead of being up in
exchange it's going to be position with
no imbalance and instead just me being
up a pond
so let's capture a pair of double rooks
now and I'm really liking just keeping
my bishop right here
I guess 97 is there isn't it and if I
move my bishop what happens b5 this
Knight is unprotected unless I play here
but still it's very awkward so what I'm
getting at is maybe I should just play
here and allow the bishop to be captured
it seems something seems off with that -
we're headed in opposite color Bishop
ending if that that happens what a pain
Bishop here b5 I could take is that
working out I think it does actually
work out let me go here mmm bit awkward
bit awkward I think watching over my
knight is important though watch over
that night okay now I could take
so let's take this bishop can't get
active I have this square covered by my
rook and now I should take with my
bishop on this night now if Knight here
I don't I can't I don't want to do this
I think I just want to move my knight
soon I also need a flight square I think
this is best age three I'm under a
minute on that night twice what a pain
uh I really would just want to like take
here something let me just try that I
want to give something back just so I
could get here I have two pawns and a
minor piece threatening a fork I'm just
doing this to buy some time get my King
involved there's a bishop check I'm not
too worried about that they aren't going
quick I also have control over this I'm
gonna take that I have two bishops okay
this is uh it's just good here don't
quick grab this pawn now that knight is
pinned over here rook activity stopped
that night from going to d7 just give a
check and bump up go go go go go hang on
hang on hang on hang on
okay now the night is falling bishop sir
Bishop's are rolling right now mate in
three possibility one to making two
possibility okay there's just
sidestepping some checks and then that's
it I'm g8
oh man okay good game snows hard let me
back up flip this here and let's see so
Sicilian dragon marcozzi bind Roxy bind
right here is a six the move I think the
other one to be going with is a Knight
takes Bishop takes Bishop to e6 I can't
be a hundred percent sure of that
I also have seen after the move you've
played instead of E 5 and this is
probably the biggest point because then
d6 becomes very weak so consider Knight
here
actually I'm still liking Bishop e6
within like Knight d7 basically like a a
man repositioning type of thing or not
repositioning but a rearrangement of the
pieces where you play your Bishop to e6
to watch over d5 and then once it's a
lot shouldered by the Bishop then you
maneuver your Knight to d7 welcome a
dark square Bishop exchange and then
maybe look to get the Queen's off with
the later Queen to b6 since your knight
again would be on d7 at that point so
Bishop here in 97 dark square Bishop
exchange your knight could also just I
the c5 e 5 squares and then you can
still try for maybe that b5 advance or
even I was saying Queen b6 maybe there's
even Queen to a5 or something but I
think there's something off with the e5
move because of just this square being
already well under my control and now
it's just something that's a while it's
all it's a whole now at this point but
that turns out to become difficult to
defend you do it the rook I guess you're
having to like go backwards but this is
again a position to just avoid
altogether